you
[Music]
good morning everyone so it's my very
great pleasure to introduce cutting neck
from the University of Maryland at the
month he's a fifth year PhD student
under profit cats and profit and he has
been a recipient of a Google fellowship
in security and he'll be talking as to a
stay about oblivious computation all
right oh good morning everyone I'm
really excited to be here today I'll be
talking about how to use oblivious
computation to compute on private data
and to obfuscate programs and towards
the end I'll talk little bit more about
my research in general and some of my
ongoing in which you work so it isn't we
have this scenario where we have two or
more hospitals and together they are
trying to compute information of the
type is some treatment better than some
other treatment and they want to do this
based on the joint information of all
the hospitals patient data put together
but law such as HIPAA do not allow one
hospital to share its data with another
hospital so you have this scenario where
you have input data of just patient data
that is private and yet you're trying to
perform some computation on top of this
and the computation itself may be public
you have a complementary scenario where
you have company such as 23andme which
have patented genomic algorithms and
they want to send these their programs
to the end-user in such a way that the
end user can find its own ancestry
information in this scenario critically
and me wants end users to use their
program yet not learn what the program
is doing because the program forms the
trade secret for such companies so you
have a dual scenario here where your
program is private but the user inputs
themselves may or may not be public so
my research has focused on designing and
building systems for such privacy
preserving computation and as I just
mentioned broadly it falls into two
categories one how to secretly outsource
data and enable computation on it and
second how to offer escape programs and
today I'm going to discuss this with the
lengths of access pattern obliviousness
which in a nutshell is the art of hiding
memory access patterns in the stock
today I am going to first discuss access
pattern obliviousness and this is going
to be a short introduction to what it is
and then I'll move on to contributions
computation on private data and find you
a fiscal of programs and towards the end
I'll talk a little bit more about my
other research on block chains and some
of my ongoing and future work so
whenever some computation is being
performed you have a CPU and memory
where your memory will store your data
and your program and whenever an
instruction is being executed on the
address and data bus you will have the
the corresponding memory location that
is being accessed and the data would if
I were to enable computation on private
data
the first step would be to keep this
data private and one way to achieve this
is to leverage a secure processor which
ensures that all the data in your memory
is encrypted and the data on the data
bus is also encrypted but what you still
do reveal is which memory location you
are accessing such secure processors
exist in the form of Intel SGX but the
question is you're still revealing these
addresses and whether it is okay to do
that if you look at this specific
example which says if some secret
variable is true then I'm going to
access memory location X otherwise I'm
going to access memory location Y and
just based on which memory location is
being accessed now you would know
exactly what the secret variable is and
this tells you that well access patterns
can indeed reveal some secret
information and if this seems like a toy
example there exist more relevant
attacks actually this attack is right
from the Messer lab where some
computation was being performed on JPEG
images and this is this was done using
Intel SGX and in the process just by
looking at page level access patterns
one could recover images the image to
the right from the image to the left and
this tells you access patterns can
indeed leak a lot of information about
the data and although these attacks are
relatively recent the problem of
protecting access patterns was disgusted
on three decades ago when gold reckoned
Ostrovsky came up with the notion of an
oblivious RAM which is a cryptographic
primitive to probably hide access
patterns to data in this talk today it
is not necessary for you to understand
an oubliette slam scheme as such but
just to give you
some intuition here is what all
oblivious RAM schemes do let us say I
want to access memory location 5 then an
aram scheme would access a memory
location 5 but in addition it would make
a couple more of a few more obfuscating
accesses to memory location 7 and 2 and
once I perform this axis what most of
Ram schemes do is they shuffle data
around the reason why you shuffle this
data is because if you do not shove in
it and if you want to access five again
then you may reveal some sort of
frequency or colocation information but
if you shuffle data are on perhaps if
you are still accessing five again you
would be able to hide which memory
location you're accessing and because
you are making these office getting
accesses and shuffling data you actually
end up touching more memory locations
than you need and one key metric that
you're trying to reduce in an oblivious
Ram scheme is bandwidth blow up or the
number of memory locations that is being
accessed and typical oblivious Ram
schemes have a poly log a rhythmic
banded loop so given this background one
key challenge in this space is to make
access pattern of leave isness efficient
and this we need to do given that we
know that there is a lower bound which
says if I have n passive memory
locations by passive I mean you can only
read and write to this memory then you
need to incur at least a logarithmic
overhead for every access and the base
of the logarithm over here is the number
of registers stored in the CPU so given
this lower bound one thing that you can
do is you can design a scheme that
actually meets this lower bound with as
good constants as possible or try to
circumvent this lower bound altogether
by changing the assumptions involved in
the lower bound
second whenever I have to move to
performing a large amount of computation
I would want to paralyze my computation
and turns out parallelism with
obliviousness comes up with its own set
of challenges
for example now the communication
pattern in between the processors should
not reveal any more information and this
constraint is in addition to the
standard constraints of parallel
programming where you would want to have
a low processing time and low
communication between processors and
finally I would argue whenever you want
to design a system you would want to
design it with
some practical constraints in mind for
example if I'm trying to use a secured
processor I should know exactly what
properties such a secure processor
provides and that that is useful both
for security and efficiency for instance
one question that you may ask is can the
trusted processors store state in
between invocations let us try to ask
this question to enter this GX so
whenever Intel SGX is executing some
instruction it has context of the
previous instruction it has executed so
in that sense you can think of such a
processor as being straight full but
more recently we have seen attacks
called as rollback attacks where you
could switch off an Intel SGX machine
and then provide it with an old state
and then rollback execution so in that
sense you can think of Intel SGX as
being a stateless processor and in the
second part of my talk I'm going to
discuss how such assumptions in
conjunction with obliviousness can
actually matter in security of schemes
but more generally I would say that if
privacy-preserving computation were to
be a success it is essential for the
fields of cryptography architecture
systems and programming languages to
work in conjunction with that let me
move on to discussing my contributions
towards computation and private data and
specifically I'm going to talk about a
secure graph parallel framework called
graph SC and in this framework I'm going
to show how it is usable that is you can
design programs with programming
abstractions that you already know in
such a way that this framework converts
it into an efficient parallel execution
and you achieve some notion of security
that I am going to discuss and you're
going to see results which say what took
1.4 hours previously can be performed
now 20x faster and specifically let us
take this as a running example where
let's say you have Netflix and Netflix
wants to compute user recommendations on
this data set so this data set has in
the first column you can see users in
the second column you can see movies and
in the third column you can see what
rating each user has given to the movie
and given this Netflix wants to compute
user recommendations that is for a given
user
which movie it may want the user may
want to see next and even if we don't
need security over here
one thing that Netflix would want to do
is given such data sets tend to be large
you may want to exploit parallelism and
just for expressiveness you may want to
use frameworks such as graph lab and
roughly this just once such framework in
a class of frameworks which is targeted
for a class of algorithms called graph
paddle algorithms or vertex centric
programs the reason why they are called
vertex centric programs is because at
any point in time
you're always thinking like a vertex so
a vertex in the graph based on its own
data and data of its neighbors is trying
to perform some computation for example
you can think of PageRank where the
PageRank of a webpage depends on its own
page rank and the page ranks of other
web pages that are pointing to it in
fact the example that I was describing
earlier on computing his recommendations
can be expressed as a bipartite graph
between users at one side and movies at
the other and the edges represent the
rating that a user has given to a movie
and turns out the result that I'm going
to discuss over here in general applies
to all Map Reduce operations as well so
one of the reasons why these graph
parallel frameworks are nice is because
you just need to remember three simple
abstractions and they are called scatter
gather and apply and I'm going to
explain them in turn and I'd remember
that at each point in time you need to
think of the computation as being from a
vertex this point of view what would a
vertex do next
the first abstraction is a scatter
abstraction where every vertex sends
some data to its neighboring edges and
the neighboring edges update their own
data the second of abstraction is
complementary where a vertex aggregates
data from all of its neighboring edges
and the vertex may update its own data
so the example over here shows a gather
by vertex B and finally an apply
operation in an apply operation every
vertex and every edge of apply some
function to its own data so the example
over here shows an apply on by all of
the vertices and also just having these
three abstractions
powerful for a large class of algorithms
and the reason why this graph palette
frameworks are nice is because you have
usability you just need to express
functions using these three abstractions
and then these graph padded frameworks
give you efficiency and parallelism that
is you can easily use the computer
cluster that you already have given this
the goal of graph SC was to have a
secure graph spiral framework that is to
have security in addition to all of
these three goats and graph SC gives you
exactly that so let us see what I mean
by security in this context so let us
say we have a secured processor and it
has your graph stored encrypted and it
is trying to process perform some
computation let us say computing user
recommendations what I want in the end
is to ensure that this computation does
not it hides the data in word data on
vertices and edges and second it hides
the structure of the graph that is the
fact that there is an edge in between
two vertices should not be revealed and
although I'm explaining all of this
assuming or secure processor over here
later I am going to relax that by
abstracting this secure processor using
two different parties and running a
secure computation protocol on it but
for now let us assume that we have
access to a so in this particular
example you can assume that a user just
submits an encrypted data and it just
communicates with the secured processor
in the second computation scenario it is
going to be slightly different where a
user secret shares its data to
non-corroding cloud service providers so
this is the scenario if we have access
to a single processor when we move to
multiple processors then we have an
additional challenge in terms of how to
split this computation into multiple
processors and we still need to ensure
the same properties that is we want to
hide data on vertices and edges and hide
the graph structure and turns out how
you parallelize it may have an effect on
how we achieve these properties
so given this let us try to see how we
can achieve this in our scenario our
first straw man would be just to use an
oblivious RAM and an oblivious ram
ensures that all access patterns are
oblivious and it is usable because I can
use this with any program that I like
but the problem is that oblivious ramp
constructions tend to be sequential that
is you cannot easily paralyze it and a
much more subtle constraint that you
that comes into picture is that once
your data is in an Aram all subsequent
accesses will incur a poly log rhythmic
overhead
so given parallelism was something that
obviously I did not achieve let us try
to achieve parallelism and try to do
something where for every vertex I have
a secured processor trying to perform
the computation on that vertex such a
solution will give you parallelism
easily it gives you usability because
you're still here you're still in in the
graphlab world and it also gives the
efficiency but the problem is that this
does not give you security and this is
because the communication in between one
processor and another processor will
reveal information of the existence of
an edge one way to fix this is to ensure
that there is an altar on communication
in between these processors and there
you would achieve security but now this
would be at the cost at a cost of V
squared communication one thing that
prior work has done and this was for
this specific example they came up with
a handcrafted computation that achieved
some notion of efficiency and it was
secure but the problem with such
approaches is that this was very
specific to one algorithm and for every
algorithm you'd have to you'd have to
think ground up on how to make it
parallel Naga and oblivious and they
only achieved some partial notion of
parallelism in in this case so given
this let us see what our work does and
this I'm going to explain with the key
idea involved in an oblivious gather and
this I'm going to first explain assuming
a single processor and then I'll
how to paralyze this and for this
example let us still assume that we have
this bipartite graph or let me slightly
simplify this graph so that I can fit it
on the slide and you can still think of
the vertices to the left as being users
and the vertices on the right as being
movies and let us say we have a very
simple computation that we are
performing and that is how many people
watch a particular movie so on this
vertex X in the end you would want to
see the data to being stored over here
and because you are just performing
accounting operation the data on each of
these edges is one the way I'm going to
represent my graph is using a simple
array where each cell of the array
represents either a vertex or an edge
for example the first cell over here
represents a vertex C the second cell
represents edge X and so on and so forth
and in general all what Isis are
represented by using a yellow background
the first step that I'm going to do in
this process is to sort this data using
an oblivious not operation in such a way
that a vertex is preceded by all of its
incoming edges so you are going to see
vertex X being preceded by edges ax and
BX an oblivious saut operation by
definition is data oblivious so it does
not reveal any information about your
data and now in a single sequential scan
I can perform my obligation operation so
whenever I reach an edge I'm going to
collect data and aggregate it and
whenever I reach over techs I'm going to
deposit that that data there so we
collected one and one from ax and BX and
deposited at vertex X and that is the
simple aggregation operation so over
here we are doing it for a simple
counting operation but in general you
can do this for any associative and
commutative operation WB's third
operation in principle takes a elog be
time for a graph of e edges and V
vertices
I allowed to reveal the number of
vertices and the number of vertices on
either side of the pipe the partition No
so this computation by itself does not
reveal that information so in practice
what you would end up doing over here
I'm asking what your problem formulation
you want to hide that you want to hide
that so the computation by itself does
not reveal it but what may happen is
that your input and our output structure
is such that the inputs and outputs
itself reveal how many vertices are
there well in this case I can learn the
sum of vertices and inches based on your
representation itself right No
so all of this data is going to be
encrypted so that you will not know
whether a vertex is then is a vertex or
an edge whether it's somehow oh you
would know the summation of yes
like what's the size of each partition
yes and you want to protect that yes
unless your input output the initial
input or the final output reveals that
because in many cases your final output
may just say give me values of all
vertices so you're oblivious not
operation over here takes a long time
for a graph of e edges and V vertices
and in practice you would actually end
up using so something like a bionic sort
which incurs a log squared V time and
the sequential scan requires order e
time so this requires a total work of
lob one key aspect about such an
operation is that this can be easily
paralyzed when you have multiple
processors so let us see how we do that
remember at the end of an oblivious sort
we have a vertex preceded by all of its
incoming edges and in general this
problem looks like the following you
have an array of interposed white and
yellow cells right now I think just for
this operation there is it is just
aggregated and everything is stored
encrypted okay so if I want to access
the output I should know the position of
my so once you're done with performing
so here's what the program is
to look like it will be a sequence of
scatter gather and apply operations in
in some particular order and in the end
if you want for example say data
corresponding to all world Isis I just
need to perform an oblivious or again in
such a way that the vertices are at one
end and and then you can reveal in just
that data okay so in general your
problem is going to look like the
following where you have an array of
interspersed white and yellow cells and
for every yellow cell you are going to
aggregate the data in the preceding
white cells and the goal over here is to
paralyze computation in such a way that
each of the processors performs an equal
amount of work that is you want to
distribute the graph evenly so that the
total amount of work is not too high and
in addition you want you would want to
achieve obliviousness that is the
communication in between these
processors does not reveal any
information and we do this by dividing
the array equally in between different
processors so that the number of
vertices that one processor is
responsible does not matter it is then a
summation of what Isis and edges that a
processor is responsible for and this is
done in such a way that a processor is
connected to logarithmically many other
processors and the amount of
communication in between them is
logarithmic I'm not going to go into the
details of exactly how this is achieved
but this is actually a generalization of
the more well-known
we do it on multiple processors we
implement a by tonic salt and because it
is a network sorting algorithm it's it's
easy to do that so it turns out that
problem is actually a generalization of
the more well-known parallel prefix and
problem where let's say you have an
input array and at the output for the
ith element you would want the summation
of the first time limits and let us say
we have one processor working on each
cell and this can be done easily in
logarithmic number of steps where in
each step each processor is
forming some sort of a
divide-and-conquer algorithm and this is
being done in sync with all of the
processes with that here is what the
complexity of these operations look like
if you would have used an or am baseline
it would have required a log e poly log
we type our solution for scatter and
gather can perform it in order a log V
time and for apply it can do it in order
e time and in parallel as I just
mentioned the depth of a computation is
order log Li and although did not
mention apply the depth of that
computation is constant so until now I
have assumed that we have access to a
secure processor but turns out to be
abstract this secure processor using two
non corroding cloud service providers
and we use a secure computation protocol
in between them so let me take a small
detour and explain what secure
computation is and then let us see how
we can apply this in our setting so a
second permutation protocol allows two
parties or two or more parties in this
case two parties let's say one with
input X and the other with input Y to
compute some function f of X Y in such a
way that one party does not reveal its
input to the other party and if I have
access to such a protocol let us see how
we can use this in a setting first for
my data set I can encrypt this by just
secret sharing this in between two non
corroding cloud service providers let's
say Netflix and Amazon and secret
sharing ensures that each share by
itself does not reveal any information
to either Netflix or Amazon but together
they have all the information that is
necessary to perform the computation and
now they can just run a secure
computation protocol with the algorithm
that I just described earlier and this
ensures that Netflix never learns
Amazon share and vice versa and that
means they can learn the output without
knowing the input ahead of time and this
ensures that your data on vertices and
edges is hidden and the graph structure
is also hidden so for a specific
implementation we used yos garbled
circuits and with
this on top of flex SC which is and
which is oblivious back-end and
oblivious a secure competition framework
we were working on at the time in case
you haven't heard of Yahoo's garbled
circuit that is fine it is just a secure
permutation protocol that we used
so given parallelism was one of our key
improvements the first thing we wanted
to do was try to run this on as big a
computation as we can and we did this
for the task of computing user
recommendations and the algorithm that
we implemented was sparse matrix
factorization using gradient descent and
we could do this on a movie lines data
set of size 1 million where when I say 1
million I mean the number of vertices
and number of edges in this graph to get
there is 1 million and the size of the
computation was about a trillion goblet
gates and at the time this was the
largest of a computation that was
performed using secure computation and
this we did using 128 CPU cores which is
what we had access to in our lab at the
time comparing this to prior work they
could do this computation only on size
16,000 ratings and for the same sized
data set using 32 CPU cores what took
them 1 point for us took us less than 3
and a half minutes and this 20x
improvement is primarily because of the
way we efficiently paralyze it but in
addition to parallelism we do this
generically for any program that can be
expressed in these graph parallel in the
graph parallel style and for them they
just handcrafted this computation for
this specific example how the
computation in terms of CPU memory usage
so in terms of time its yeah in terms of
time it would be so it behaves as n log
squared n so it would be almost linear
but there would be a log square
component that would also come into
picture
and the CPU usage and uh so when we
implemented this this was CPU bound
right now it is communication bound
because with newer algorithms so newer
processors have access to a es ni
because of which these computations are
now faster and now it is communication
bound so so in terms of computational
resources I'm saying it would take that
much amount of time using the same
amount of computational distance that we
are using over here if you can have
higher amount of computational resources
which I'm going to get next get to next
then you can still have possibly the
same amount of time depending on how
many resources you use so let us see how
sorry I am
follow the switch from like talking
about program and like the computation
do like secure computation ok so why is
that necessary said might be dumb
question so follow that switch okay so
the results that we have apply in both
these settings one where you have a
secular processor and you're trying to
hide memory access patterns and turns
out in secure computation the problem is
slightly different where you have a ram
program and eventually you want a
circuit and an important intermediary
over here is the notion of an oblivious
program so the the place where this
program or the these oblivious
algorithms come into picture is the
design of these oblivious algorithms
which is the hard part and once you have
an oblivious algorithm converting it
into circuits is an easy translation
I'm not sure if I again over Anna what
you're talking about so when you're
talking about the looking sort for
example do you do you still need or ever
anymore you'd like customer you know
we're just trying to get rid of an aura
over here we are not using and what I'm
altogether yeah so you could have made
so you're just trying to make it
oblivious and obliviousness and
achieving obliviousness and writing a
circuit they're synonymous so so once
you have obliviousness converting it
into a circuit is a one-to-one
translation I'm not sure sure okay so in
terms of parallelism so let us say so
this is the high level result on the
y-axis you see the execution time and on
the x-axis you see the number of
processors and both of these axes are
logs killed and the different lines over
here correspond to different graph sizes
and as you can see as we increase the
number of processors the computation
time reduces and although it is not
clear because this is a log-log scale it
is actually true that as you increase
the number of processors the decrease in
computation time is almost linear
and finally just because we had a
framework we did this for a bunch of
algorithms and not just for one specific
example and the same result holds for
all of these examples so with that I
discuss bravas see where you can take
programs returned in these abstractions
of scatter gather and apply and you can
convert them efficiently into and graph
se converts them efficiently into a
parallel execution using secure
computation with that let me move on to
the second part of my talk on office
gating programs turns out the problem of
achieving office kesshun is relatively
old and there has been a lot of
approaches to do this
there have been heuristic approaches to
obfuscate for example this is one
example and I have a question for you
what does this program do or for that
matter what does this program look like
any guesses
I think if it squinty eyes or if you go
further behind
perhaps it it would be easier sorry yes
so this is a flappy bird so a game that
was very famous I think a couple of
years ago and turns out if you execute
this program you can play flappy bird on
a terminal so such approaches to
obfuscation tend to be efficient but
they actually give you no guarantee so
on what it offers gates and at the other
end it is known that it is impossible to
achieve program of software only program
office kitchen in the strong sense so
given this we are trying to come up with
a scheme for office keishon by by using
some other assumptions there have been
approaches in cryptography to achieve
this for example they have introduced
this notion of indistinguishability
office keys which is at this point
inefficient and not strong enough in
practice they have introduced this
notion of using secure hardware or
trusted hardware tokens but turns out
most of these schemes use strong
cryptography primitives such as fully
homomorphic encryption or
non-interactive zero-knowledge close or
they just try to obfuscate boolean
programs instead of Ram programs there
have been approaches in the architecture
community but most of these approaches
are used to hide inputs and assume
public programs and many of these
architects architectural solutions
actually reveal access buttons given
that our goal was to our goal in Hope
which stands for hardware makes office
kitchen practical was to achieve an
efficient of vision scheme using a
trusted processor and we prototyped a
hardware system to do the same in this
process we introduced some optimizations
which allowed us to perform up to 240 X
better than a baseline scheme while
still being up to 76 X slower than an
insecure system before I explain what
our office kitchen scheme is let me
quickly define exactly what security
properties we are looking for and let us
say in this ideal world where we have
access to a trusted third party we have
weighed on who has a program he would
like to office Kate he wants everyone to
use it but not learn what this program
is doing and let us say Jonathan is
trying to execute this program on his
own inputs so all Jonathan will do so
alway dong will do is send his program
to the trusted third party and Jonathan
will just send his input to the trusted
third party which will execute this and
give a result back and let's say in
addition to the output it also reveals
size of the program and some execution
time which is fixed for all inputs of
the same size the reason why we're
thinking of jonathan has being the
adversary over here is because he's the
one who's trying to learn the program
and in the ideal world he never has
access to the program because it is the
trusted third party who is who has
access to the program
Jonathan only has an Oracle access to
the program in the real world sorry so
and we want this we want to ensure this
for all inputs that Jonathan may have in
the real world instead you have this
scenario where you have a secured
processor which may have a small amount
of trusted storage and it stores
everything outside in an encrypted form
and in this new world what you can do is
wait on can send his program in an
encrypted form to Jonathan and Jonathan
can just send the program and as input
to the trusted processor and which will
perform an execution with the main
memory and finally return the output
we're going to assume that the adversary
has access to this entire memory all
throughout and in such a way that he can
modify parts of memory if he likes
because we are envisioning this
computation to be local and what you
want is the kind of obfuscation
guarantee that you get to the left to be
the same as the one on the right oh no
one encrypt strange but because it is
the adversary who's trying to run this
program on his input I was confused by
the log as you say Oh
all right and it turns out assumptions
of the form weathered such a trusted
processor can store state in between in
locations actually matters for security
so first we are going to assume that
such a trusted processor can store state
in between invocations that is we have a
stateful processor and let us try to
construct an obfuscation scheme in this
scenario so whenever some execution is
happening at every point in time the
processor is going to read an
instruction and this instruction can be
a simple move instruction or an
arithmetic instruction or it can
actually be a memory access and whether
or not it is a memory access is
something that is available to the
adversary so the first thing you would
want to do is you want to hide whether
it's a memory access or not and one way
to do this is to ensure that for every
non memory access you actually perform a
memory accesses well second based on
what I have been saying earlier we would
want to protect our access patterns and
use an oblivious RAM over here third
because the adversary has access to the
entire memory and he can modify parts of
it your trusted processor would want to
authenticate memory at all points in
time to ensure that the memory is not
modified and it would keep an
authentication token within itself and
finally you would want to run this
program for a fixed time T for all
inputs of same size just so that the
adversary does not learn how the program
behaves for different inputs of the same
size and this is what I'm going to refer
to as a baseline scheme or later on in
my evaluation and turns out if you do
this you will achieve some notion of
obfuscation if you are running a single
application if you're running multiple
applications let's say concurrently in
that case the state corresponding to one
program needs to move out of the token
so that you can feed it with the state
corresponding to to the other program
and such context switching motivates the
formulation of a stateless processor
again a stateless processor is something
that does not maintain state between
invocations so at the end of the
invocation it would give out an
encrypted state that it stores and it
would expect the adversary to send this
state back at the next invocation and
if I have such a stateless processor
here is something that an adversity can
do he will execute the first ten
instructions and now it is the turn of
the adversary to execute the lemons
instruction say but the adversary will
send the state corresponding to the
tenth instruction again and make the
process of execute the tens instruction
again and based on two executions of the
tens instruction it will try to learn
more information and turns out such an
attack which we call a rewinding attack
in such an attack in this scenario and
adversity can actually learn information
and and the problem is that oblivious
Rams are not secured against such
rewinding adversaries because I have not
explained an oblivious Rams scheme as
such in this talk I will not go into the
details of the exact attack involved
over here but what I will still give you
is an intuitive but imprecise
explanation of why that happens let us
say my memory location of interest is
memory location five and the two of us
gating accesses are two seven and two if
I remind execution if and if I run it
again I still need to access memory
location five because that is needed for
my correctness guarantees but the two of
us creating accesses maybe to two
different locations and if I remind if I
keep reminding and if I just perform a
set intersection operation then I would
exactly know which memory location
you're accessing and although oblivious
ramps are used to hide memory access
patterns we are not achieving that at
all
is it because you don't want to assume
that the entire computation is done in
one go that was it Academy let's reboot
the machine in between and yes like why
is that a practical concern like the
adversary because just start on the
beginning in like whoa what kind of
programs are you thinking like where you
are this log reading programs so any
program that may be long-running
because so such computations tend to be
much slower than existing computations
so if you want the context switch one
way to do this is to ensure that your
processor is stateful and it remembers
context of what's outside
precisely so if you can maintain that
and if you have a stateful processor
well and good you can do that but what
we show is that even if you do not
remember or if your processor does not
remember this information you can still
achieve the same guarantees so so
specifically over here we make sure that
the adversary commits to this program
and input ahead of time and and then you
use your randomness based on a
pseudo-random function that depends on
the program and the input and in this
case even if you rewind you will still
make sure that this you use the same of
us getting accesses so with that I have
explained some of the key elements
involved in this construction let me
move on to quickly describing the
optimizations and quickly describing the
architecture of the system so we have to
optimizations over here
the first optimization tries to reduce
the number of memory locations that you
are accessing and this we and this we
need to do because Oram accesses tend to
be expensive compared to arithmetic
instructions and this at a high level
over here we are just trying to
interleave the number of arithmetic and
memory accesses and the second
optimization over here tries to use a
small amount of trusted storage within
the secured processor and if you have
programs that exhibit locality you would
not you would incur a scratch pad access
instead of for main memory access so
here is what the architecture of the
system looks like we have a secured
coprocessor which works in conjunction
with the host processor which is the
adversary and your data is stored in an
our memory which is encrypted we started
off with the RISC Phi started off with
the very lock code corresponding to this
five processor and we modified this to
include a scratchpad load instruction
which was used to feed the data and
instructions crash part for an oblivious
ram we used
a variant of Passover I'm called free
Kosovo RAM and this is something that
was built previously and finally we had
encryption and decryption units to
ensure that all that it outside is
stored encrypted and here is what the
high-level result looks like on the
y-axis you have slow down to in secular
execution and on the x-axis you have
different programs that we have
implemented and the two bars refer to
the baseline scheme and to our
construction so baseline scheme is
something that I described much earlier
and Hoppus baseline with the two
optimizations and the high level result
is that corresponding the baseline
scheme we perform up to 240 X better and
and just so that we can see the y-axis
and slow around to insecure execution of
how clearly let me move this to a
logarithmic scale so the y-axis is now
look at me and and the high level result
over here is that compared to insecure
execution we perform in the range of 8 X
276 X works worse so programs such as
binary search which exhibit no degree of
locality they perform up to 76 X works
but for programs such as burrows-wheeler
transform which have a high degree of
locality they perform up to 8x worse
with that I have discussed a secure of
fisken scheme which has been designed
with architectural constraints in mind
one key addition that is necessary in
this space is some programming language
support so that the developer can easily
specify how to use a scratch pad or
hopefully it's not going to be the
developers concerned on how the scratch
pad is used so with that I have spoken
about my work on computing on private
data and obfuscation of programs let me
try to speak about my research a little
more in general my research has focused
broadly in two areas one is on privacy
preserving computation and second has
been towards blockchains in privacy
preserving computation I spoke about
parallelism in of mill oblivious
execution and office gated program
execution in the first section I have
worked towards a bunch of papers on
oblivious Rams and oblivious programs
for example I have worked towards
designing an oblivious Ram scheme which
actually
the gold across torski lower bound
although we actually change one of the
assumptions that is we assume a private
information retrieval protocol but for
the change assumption we show a new
lower bound saying you cannot do
anything better even in this scenario I
have also worked towards the notion of
having an oblivious data structure so
let us say an adversary already knows
that your you just have a map data
structure or a tree a data structure and
in that case trying to hide which
operations are being performed and turns
out these oblivious data structures can
be faster than an aura and finally I
have I'm presently working towards the
notion of achieving locality in
conjunction with obli business as well
as the notion of achieving perfect
security with obliviousness
and then in the area of block chains I
have worked towards adversarial behavior
in block chains where we have tried to
attack the Bitcoin protocol as well as I
have worked towards the design of robust
block chains both in the permissioned as
well as permissionless settings with
that let me move on to speaking a little
bit about my future work the overarching
goal over here is to move from privacy
preserving computation to a privacy
preserving system until now we have been
discussing having private inputs
performing some computation on top of it
and learning some data models for
instance we considered Netflix ratings
as being our private input and user
recommendations as being the output but
in an actual system you may end up
revealing this information through other
means through other obvious auxilary
means for example if it's the Netflix
this example just the fact that you're
streaming movies from Netflix already
tells it that I'm watching this movie
and and that in practice can hurt you
second the data model itself in some
cases can reveal a lot of information
about your private inputs and if that
happens the entire privacy-preserving
computation you are doing in-between is
rendered useless so you may want to
introduce use notions of differential
privacy in conjunction with secure
computation to ensure that you still
have some realistic guarantees on your
private inputs second you want to move
on to a broader class of functions
such as doing privacy-preserving neural
networks of privacy preserving genomic
tasks has also designed functions that
are better suited for secure computation
or that a faster and secure computation
looking at slightly long-term we would
want to consider alternative security
definitions one such example over here
would be for obliviousness right now we
are thinking of trying to hide all
access patterns but what if you were to
think of obliviousness as being a
spectrum between leaking all access
patterns and hiding all access patterns
and now we can try to pick a point in
between in a way that you leaked some
accesses in such a way that you achieve
some security for some in some realistic
notion the eventual goal over here is to
ensure that a user or an organisation
can specify policy on how her data or
program can be used and if all such
users have such a policy a company who's
trying to provide user specific features
actually adheres to this policy and the
privacy preserving system actually
ensures this in the space of robust
block chains I'm interested in combining
the merits of the classical consensus
protocols and the new permissionless
protocols as well as trying to achieve
the notion of confidentiality and
efficiency together and block scenes
before ending my talk I would like to
thank all of my collaborators without
whom none of my research would have been
possible thank you and I'd be happy to
take questions
I won't question you said that in the
Netflix experiment it took a minute
special minutes what if for the
unsecured scheme how long to take
science it's been blaming this now the
issue of what for that particular
example the ratio of insecure to secure
or secure to insecure is 10 to the
fourth
let's take a computation 10 to the
fourth let's check your computation 10
to the 4 so what takes 1 minute we'll
take 10,000 minutes and if you assume a
trusted processor there's been parallel
work at Berkeley and over there with the
same algorithms it is around a factor of
I think 40 to 80
so why do you think a notion of like
non-binary security like somewhere in
the middle is a good idea
oh because you'll get some notion of
efficiency yeah definitely talking about
the oblivious metric right right yeah so
if you can try to reduce the number of
accesses or the number of oblivious
accesses you will get some notion of
efficiency right but like your wouldn't
it be very hard to define what secure
your privacy really means that is
something that I'm presently working on
and trying to understand what security
exactly means in that context you're
right it's not so easy to define so so
so one one notion that can be
interesting is the notion of trays
differentially private computation so
that you reveal some accesses in such a
way that the differential privacy of
users is still maintained and and that
may not be applicable for all inputs so
instead of thinking of oblivia has
obliviousness as being the worst case
scenario where for any input time I'm
going to give you a solution if you have
let's say maybe a distribution on inputs
or something along those lines you're
trying to hide something specific again
I'm not being very specific here because
this is not something that I have
thought about entirely but but this
notion seems like a reasonable one that
we can try to work on what I do
understand is a for the proverb of
vacation why do they require only a
preview server because if I if the
problem was encrypted even though the
access it's a very hard to reverse
engineer the original programmer so I
think a simple example would be if I
have a program which performs binary
search versus a program that is adding
elements in an array just based on
access patterns you would not know
exactly this is what it is doing but
perhaps you should be able to figure out
that at some point in time that is what
it is doing
that's only a hyzer to a very simple
right if I sure to get provable
guarantees in terms of having a
cryptographic proof so you're right even
in the generic case it may be very hard
to actually construct an attack but over
here what we are trying to show is that
if you have something like this you will
never be able to reconstruct or come up
with an attack there are cases that
people care about the program of
fascination right I don't
and in those real-world cases it is
obvious or are unnecessary so so I would
say if in in real-world cases if if they
care about these settings then you want
to actually hide the program and in that
case yes oblivious Ram would be
necessary so the if you're doing
did you have a question
of butts in particular
[Applause]
you